welcome everybody this is an area that I
have been researching for quite some
time I basically started in the mid 90s
I had a project the first project I was
going to do for my PhD originally was on
DNA computing and actually invented a
scheme for universal computing using DNA
chemistry and it turned out that because
of the laws of thermochemistry the DNA
computer we designed could either take
forward steps or backward steps through
the computation and so in order to make
any forward progress
it had to be reversible because
otherwise there would be more ways to go
backwards than to go forwards and so it
would just tend to go backwards right so
sort of motivated by this I started
studying reversible computing in more
depth and turned towards electronic
implementations of reversible computing
which were a lot more practical
certainly in the near term so my talk
today is going to basically be a brief
survey of sort of the motivation in
terms of that an end of semiconductor
scaling which we just heard about and
then we can sort of break down the
sources of energy dissipation and
computing and to energy that's
dissipated at different levels in a
computer design and what we find is that
a lot of the proposals for
unconventional models or styles of
computing are motivated by attacking
energy dissipation at one or more of
these levels reducing the waste getting
rid of inefficiencies and so forth and
I'm going to argue that's all well and
good but there's really only one
physically possible
unconventional paradigm that actually
can potentially attack energy
dissipation at all the levels in
computing and reduce it by as far as we
know right now indefinitely large
factors so if we want there to be any
hope for sort of a very long-term
sustainable future for
the performance growth in computing
reversible computing has to be a part of
that you can layer on top of that other
types of unconventional computing
architectural changes and so forth but
that reversible computing element has to
be there it's unavoidable
so I'll explain why that is starting
with the discussion of Landauer's
principle which gives sort of the
fundamental physical motivation for why
old-style irreversible computing is not
good enough and then I'll talk about
definitions of models of reversible
computing that you can derive from the
fundamental thermodynamics don't need
that and I'll serve a briefly a few
types of examples of implementations of
reversible computing that have been
proposed and this field really feels
still in its infancy it's never received
very much funding there's never been a
whole lot of attention paid to it I
think that what we can do in the future
when designers turn more of their
attention towards reversible computing
there's going to be a huge explosion of
implementation concepts right now
there's a relatively small handful of
them and I'll focus on three general
classes of implementations that have
been explored in more depth than than
others I've seen but there are others
out there so again as we just heard the
motivation for this is the end of the
semiconductor roadmap in terms of
continued scaling of transistors and for
performance with in power dissipation
limits the key figure of Merit is
essentially energy dissipation per
operation well when you look at the
lowest level at the energy dissipated
and locally or moderately non locally
connected logic gates you find that
there's a couple of different ways you
can
discuss energy dissipation you can talk
about what's the minimum energy required
to switch the state of a minimum size
transistor right so that's essentially
the energy stored on the gate
capacitance of that transistor and
that's this lower curve do we have a
pointer by the way okay so this lower
blue curve here is plotting the minimum
gate energy thanks and you can see these
are figures from the international
technology roadmap for semiconductors
which I've recently become involved with
and you can see that these this is sort
of asymptoting out and the reason for
that is that the framers of the ITRs are
aware that there are some apparent of
fundamental thermal limits having to do
with thermal noise so essentially once
the gate energy on a minimum size
transistor gets down to the range of
several tens of KT you find that
essentially there's going to nineveh
tably beef thermal fluctuations and the
potential energy surface in the channel
and those are going to lead to increased
leakage which you can combat by raising
device thresholds but then that slows
down the device so then the net effect
is lower device performance so you
basically get diminishing returns from
shrinking transistors as you as you
approach this energy scale now that's
not really the energy dissipated per bit
in CMOS designs because why well in real
designs transistors tend not to be
minimum size they tend to be sized for
best performance depending on what logic
networks they're driving so typical
transistor with could be as much as you
know 10 or 20 times minimum width in
addition to this you
parasitic capacitances and the PN
junctions of the of the transistor you
have multiple transistors in each logic
gate that are being driven by a given
signal given signal tend to fan out
towards several logic gates and then
there's wire capacitance depending on
the length of the wire and how local the
circuit is but when you multiply all
these factors together you get hundreds
of times more energy stored in a typical
logic node than is in the minimum size
transistor gate itself and this is kind
of inevitable from the way we design
circuits today I mean you can't really
there's no more no sort of magical way
to eliminate all of those overheads even
if you try going to like a cellular
automata architecture where all the
connections are local well you still
need to communicate information over
longer distances to interact data that
does not happen to be located next to
each other and so it doesn't really
doesn't really help at a systems
engineering level to make those kind of
architectural changes so anyway the end
result is that the total energy
dissipated is some factor like 500 or so
times the minimum transistor energy and
so that's leveling off and we see that
this is leveling off at you know even
though this is a level of a few evey
this is leveling off at a kilo electron
volt which is essentially reflecting
that on the complete circuit no
distributed to several logic gates
there's going to be several thousand
electrons sitting there you know at a
volt or so and that's kind of inevitable
well you know one electron is not going
to be enough to to sort of cover that
whole structure and so when we
essentially when you ground a circuit
node you're dissipating all those that
ke V of stored electrical energy to heat
okay and so we really want to avoid that
and for a long time people said oh well
reversible computing is not relevant
because we're so far from Landauer's
principle why do we care but look
these multipliers are real it's not just
you know thermal limits that are
important it's this large factor larger
than thermal limit amount of energy per
circuit node that we inevitably are
going to have we have to try to recycle
that energy or there's no way we're
gonna get below this kV level okay
at least not with you no ordinary
electronics okay you can try and move to
something else like superconducting or
optical and I'll say a little bit more
about those later so so you really have
to begin recycling circuit energies and
then that leads to the concept of
reversible computing because you can
only completely recover or approach full
full recovery of signal energies if your
computation is logically reversible and
I'll explain why that is in a bit so
sort of my general argument is that
we're very quickly approaching the end
of the roadmap and really only
reversible computing can take us from
there far into the future indefinitely
far even below the länder 11 and we'll
talk about why that is so the fact that
we have in conventional technology these
apparent you know limits on energy
efficiency you know it has severe
implications for supercomputing which is
why Sandia is interested in this area
frankly because they do a lot of
supercomputing it at Sandia they're
always trying to improve the performance
and capability of their machines right
now a lot of people in our Center are
involved with the exascale computing
program which is aiming to get an
exaflop scale supercomputer by around
2021 so about four more years and it's a
very aggressive schedule and it's not
really completely clear if you're we're
really gonna hit the power performance
targets that we want but in any case
that's an exaflop so we'll probably get
there that you can do almost with
today's technology but then you know
even at the end of the semiconductor
roadmap you're only going to be able to
get a little
bit beyond that at reasonable power
levels right and then if you want to ask
how you know how much power will it take
to do is that a flop well even at the
end of the roadmap we're talking about
more than a gigawatt for a supercomputer
I mean that's like you know comparable
to Hoover Dam in terms of total power
load and that's optimistic that's even
ignoring the overhead for interconnects
and cooling systems and all of that
which is real overhead that has to be
accounted for and then you know even if
you say well maybe we can reduce
dissipation per operation to near that
thermal noise limit and somehow get rid
of all the architectural overheads I
just mentioned you know even then we're
still it's gonna be more than a megawatt
I think a lots of people would be happy
with a megawatt scale zero flop computer
but what if you want to go beyond that
right even more flops and so you find
that you know basically the the future
of computing is gonna haul forever
unless we do irreversible computing
that's the only thing that can take us
into this red wedge and as far as we
know and definitely far into it okay so
I feel like you know we've really got to
start paying attention to this right if
we don't it's sort of at our peril you
know of the whole industry is going to
stagnate and there's essentially no
question about this physically unless we
master this new technology alright so
this is sort of my slide giving an
overview of energy dissipation at
different scales in computing and how
this relates to unconditional and
computing paradigms and people like to
you know point out they say oh
reversible computing is only affecting
the logic gate but we have all these
overheads at other levels so why are we
where are we doing in and there are
overheads certainly you know just
cooling a data center is you know a
significant chunk of total power
consumption and you know it's hard to
eliminate the cooling overhead you can
try to site your data center in Iceland
or something or you know an extreme
example would be in a
at the moon where the permanently shaded
craters are like 30 40 Kelvin but you
know short of crazy things like that
there's not much you can do to improve
the efficiency of cooling systems
then there's networking a huge amount of
the power consumption of modern data
centers and supercomputers is in the
interconnects between nodes and then
memory systems are a big chunk you know
not only the energy to keep the memory
refreshed if it's DRAM but also the i/o
the to provide the memory bandwidth that
that applications demand and so for
things like networking and even more
local interconnects optical is being
pushed as a solution
there's also processing and memory type
architectures that try to locate more of
the processing closer to the memory
those things are quite helpful opticals
even being looked at for board level and
within packages and you know some crazy
far out people are even looking at
optical in between transistors right and
we don't really know how to do that
efficiently yet but people are looking
at that so that's that's nice there's
also overheads due to the architecture
itself so you know traditional
microprocessor has an instruction set
and a lot of the gate operations in that
market process or are just going to
interpreting this instruction set
scheduling instructions you know
managing various queues and buffers in
the microarchitecture and so on and so
if you get rid of the instruction set
and you go to some lower level like you
configure an FPGA or you have some
specialized architecture like a GPU or a
neural architecture or you know the
extreme is you make a full custom ASIC
specifically for your application you
can gain quite a bit of performance you
know two or three orders of magnitude
even compared to a record processor and
that's great but it's a
limited finite sort of gain that you can
get there eventually those low-hanging
fruit will be picked you know all of the
important kernels will be compiled into
you know Asics that are part of these
heterogeneous systems that need them and
you won't get any further gains beyond
that then there's the wiring themselves
you know I talked about that already as
a factor in energy dissipation and one
thing that's been looked at is low
voltage switches although there hasn't
been any great empirical success yet so
far as I've heard in terms of actually
being able to get really steep
sub-threshold slopes and you know beyond
the limit for for field effect
transistors but people are still trying
you know but you know the danger of
lowering the signal energy is what I
just mentioned this thermal noise limit
right and I think that's going to still
cause problems even in various low
voltage device technology so I don't
think that they're gonna give you any
sort of magical way around that limit
then there's the overheads of logic gate
structures themselves and you know we've
had a lot of generations of development
of CMOS technology and I you know I
think the the gate designs are about as
good as we're going to get unless we go
to adiabatic circuits which we'll talk
about and then I you know I already
mentioned how there's this thermal noise
limit on the gate energies themselves so
they're not gonna continue getting
smaller now people say oh why are we
doing reversible competing it's just
helping the logic gates what about all
these higher levels well they also can
be reduced by reversible computing
communication networks can use
reversible methods to charge up
interconnect lines memory devices you
can define memory interfaces that are
reversible and you can do that virtually
as well leakage is always a problem for
reversible as well as irreversible
technology but if you have a good if you
find a good non-volatile memory device
that's not dissipating a lot of energy
doesn't need a lot of active refreshing
you can operate that in a reversible
mode and reduce power dissipation in the
memory system the memory interface and
all of that right so there's no reason
to think that you can't apply reversible
computing at all of these levels all
right there may be unique issues and
complexities at each of the levels but
as far as we know we can we can apply it
everywhere it's sort of a universal
principle in computing and digital data
manipulation in general I'm just gonna
very quickly show a couple of slides
that are just here to sort of illustrate
that work is being done at Sandia at
number of these levels for different
kinds of unconventional technologies so
this is a slide on you know some work on
optical systems at Scindia there's been
a lot of work on silicon photonics where
you know optical devices are integrated
on chip you know and processes that are
compatible with CMOS technology and you
know this isn't my specialty so I'm not
going to say a lot about this because I
frankly I don't know a lot other than
what is on the slide that you can read
through yourself but there is a fair bit
of work being done it at Sandia there's
strong belief that you know this is
going to become increasingly important
for interconnect and high-performance
computing
and it's expected the exascale systems
will contain a fair amount of optical
hardware it's another area being worked
out at Sandia is neural computing we see
sort of neural computing it's a class of
accelerators that are not necessarily
going to speed up all computations but
for computations that have a significant
learning component that's needed or
pattern recognition something that can
be compiled into a neural framework
efficiently neural hardware can
potentially give you some of these
you know constant factor energy benefits
compared to running a similar algorithm
on a general-purpose processor so you
know there's a number of facets to the
the interest in neural computing at
sandia one major project at Sandia that
just finished is the hana grand
challenge and there's a number of facets
to that project they spent a fair bit of
time looking at crossbar architectures
developing new spiking neural network
architectures looking at low level
devices for speeding up neural computing
such as memristors and electrochemical
transistors and there's a lot of
interesting work there and there's some
references down there by the way are the
slides gonna be provided or posted yeah
so if anyone needs to see those
references and can check them out later
you know that's not my area so I don't
really know anything about that anyway
so I'm not gonna talk about that I'll
talk a little bit about CMOS a little
bit about superconducting and a little
bit of other stuff okay so that was all
I was gonna say about other
unconventional competing approaches
besides reversible computing as you can
tell I'm a big fan of reversible
computing and so this is what I'm gonna
focus on first like a brief primer on
thermodynamics of information sort of
the modern physics understanding of
entropy is it's essentially statistical
uncertainty about the microstate of a
physical system and by microstate we
mean you can refer to a set of
distinguishable quantum states of the
system as being the microstates and
physics as we know it is by ejected in
the in the case of quantum theory
it's believed to be unitary it's doing
essentially a one-to-one transformation
in the space of state vectors and
because of that any initial probability
distribution over the microstates if you
tracked the exact unitary evolution of
quantum system you'd get the same
probabilities coming out you've got a
one-to-one map from old States to new
states so there's no change in entropy
at that level
neither increases nor decreases and the
fact that this relationship is
one-to-one is in fact it's the reason
why the second law of thermodynamics is
true because if States did not map one
to one on a new States you could have
two states with some you know some
probabilities associated with them that
merge into a single state and when that
happens the probabilities combine it but
the entropy associated with that state
it will always be will be always be less
if these are nonzero probabilities and
so entropy would decrease spontaneously
in those cases and since this never
happens in Pyrrhic lis we essentially
know that whatever fundamental laws of
physics are they have to be injective
now why can't repeat increase well if we
increase can be understood it's simply a
consequence of the fact that we can't
perfectly track the evolution of a
system we can't keep track of all the
correlations that arise when systems
become entangled with each other and in
general when they interact with each
other and also we don't know the laws of
physics exactly we don't know the
fundamental constants to infinite
precision so you know given that you
don't know exactly what transformation
is happening even if even though we know
that underlying transformation is
one-to-one since we don't know exactly
what one-to-one transformation is
happening the probability distribution
ends up getting more fuzzy over time so
in a sense the second law of
thermodynamics can be understood is it's
essentially just a consequence of
injectivity of micro physics and the
fact that entropy can increase is a
consequence of the fact that we have
imperfect knowledge about
physics and about in a perfect ability
of tracking the state of a system now
some people say oh that's great there's
physical entropy but what about
computational interviews and that's
something different information entropy
Shannon entropy is that's something
different that's about logical valid
values and knowledge about logical
states well it's really not different
because what is a computational state
it's just an aggregate or a set of
physical states that we consider
equivalent for computational purposes
right that definition goes back to
Shannon but I don't think anyone could
sensibly question that definition of
what a computational state is and it
turns out that you know given that we
can group states you can break down the
total entropy of the system using the
chain rule of conditional entropy and
you can say the total entropy it's just
the entropy of the probability
distribution over your computational
States plus a conditional entropy of the
physical state given the computational
state right and so it's essentially
computational entropy plus the physical
entropy if the computational state were
known that is total entropy all right
and this is just a theorem right there's
a theorem of conditional entropy that
tells you this this is just a little
visualization I came up with to help
understand this you know so if this is a
probability distribution over States and
the thickness of the line as the
probability and the length is that is
essentially the log of 1 over
probability then you know if you group
States together that's just sort of
rearranging this tree but it's not
changing the total area of the branches
which is the total entropy all right so
you know there's essentially no question
about this physical entropy is it's just
a part of our sorry computational
entropy it's just a part of the total
physical entry of the system there's no
way around that
ok so this in turn leads directly to
Landeros principle ok so you have
computational states that are just sets
of physical States so let's say you have
a bit you know two possible
additional states and you want to erase
the bit so you want the new state to now
be say zero unconditionally whether or
not that previous state was zero or one
well essentially you're merging then two
sets of physical states into a single
computational state and because the
underlying dynamics has to be by ejected
and because the total entropy is always
exactly computational entropy plus
non-computational entropy you know what
happens when you do this merger is the
computational entropy has to decrease
because you're combining the
probabilities together and so the non
computational entropy has to increase
right so in this example we've lost one
bit of computational entropy because
each of these states at probability 0.5
and so we have to gain one bits worth of
non-computational entropy you know it's
just Falls directly out of this trivial
algebra okay all right so I never can
understand why people question Lanterns
principle because all the stuff is just
so dead simple there are some subtleties
maybe that if you don't understand they
can trip you up so what are we talking
about in Lanter Sprint's Bowl when we
say we have computational entropy well
really information in a computer it may
not you may not consider it in a strict
sense because in a sense it's known
information information that you've
computed from some inputs you've
provided it's sort of logically implied
by the infant you provided it's not
unknown information in that sense but
Landeros principle still applies it's
still information and so a way that you
can model these types of situations is
some input comes in you do some
computation on it which here I'm
modeling with a controlled-not operator
that just XOR is the first bit into the
second one and you know with this
previous slide you know we saw we can
like move information back and forth
between the computational and
non-computational domains that just sort
of depends on where you draw the
boundaries I mean your computational
states and whoops
so there's you know there's no reason
you can't sort of take this computed bid
and move it into the environment with
some reversible transformation but the
thing is about the environment when you
say it's non-computational that sort of
implies it's this uncontrolled
environment right so we're not sort of
explicitly manipulating the states it's
a thermal environment it's subject to
all kinds of noise you can have some
random mixing of states that happens in
the environment so you can't assume that
any correlation president and in their
environment will be maintained I mean
even if it's maintained by the raw
physics we can't track that evolution
right we're not able to track the
correlations once they escape into a
thermal environment right so that's
essentially why entropy must increase
when you move it out of a computer
because you've taken something that was
just a correlated bit it wasn't true
entropy really you moved into the
environment now it becomes randomized so
that's irreversible okay
so there's no way around that um I was
just at a talk on thermodynamics of a
workshop in thermodynamics of
computation at Santa Fe Institute a few
weeks ago and you know the the
thermodynamics is there I was surprised
they didn't seem to understand this but
then after I showed the slide they got
real quiet and you know they seem to
understand it after that all right now
here's the difference in reversible
computing you have a computed bit now
instead of pushing it out into the
environment you simply do another
computation on that bit which one
trivial way to do this is just the time
reverse of the original computation that
produced that bit if that was a
reversible computation and then that
restores that bit to some standard state
so here zero right so now this is sort
of free memory you've temporarily used
some memory to compute some result and
then you undo that and now you got free
remember again what you can reuse for
another computation and this is sort of
the most trivial example but you can do
this with arbitrarily complex
computations and that's reversible
competing and you don't care what's HAP
in the environment because you haven't
pushed any of your digital bits out into
the environment the environment can
initially be in a random state and they
could rear a num rise that stayed all at
once and then you don't care because
it's not affecting the entropy in your
computational system if this is already
at maximum entropy its entropy is not
increasing further so you can
theoretically get by with no entropy
increase in these types of structures
and this this was essentially the basic
concept behind this was first discovered
by Bennett and 73 I mean Landau sort of
anticipated it but didn't fully
understand that it could work and then
Bennett showed how it could work at a
logical level so all right that's sort
of a preview so now let's see if we can
formalize this notion of reversible
computing a little more we wanted to
find what reversible computing is well
fundamentally what are we doing when
we're developing reversible computing
and we're answering the question of what
are the conditions that must be met at
the logical level in a computer in order
to avoid ejecting entry from the
computational State this thing that we
saw happened you know in Leonard's
principle where we had some entropy that
was originally in a computational state
and then we pushed it out in the
environment and now it's in the non
computational state where you can't get
it back you can't uncomputable paper was
trying to sort of define some intuitive
notion for what needed to be the case to
avoid this entropy increase and you know
he came up with this thing he called
logical reversibility he said let's map
one to one the whole space of say two to
the N possible States for an n-bit
device let's map that whole set of
states one to one on two new stage then
there's no merging of states and so
there doesn't have to be any entry
increase okay well that's fine for what
it is but it turns out that's although
it's a sufficient condition for physical
reversibility it's not the least
restrictive possible sufficient
condition so it's not strictly
unnecessary in there
all right so to show why we have to sort
of carefully define some concepts you
know a device I think of as a physical
artifact that can perform computational
operations an operation itself it's just
a map from Old State to news-8 you can't
have stochastic maps in a theory of
stochastic devices I don't get into that
I'm just talking about deterministic
devices at this level although the
theory could be extended to non
deterministic or stochastic operations
and then this is important that the
notion of a computation that we're going
to use it's not just some operation
we're performing but it's also a
statistical operating context and you
have to have that really to even define
quantities like entropy you have to have
a probability distribution to give any
kind of precise definition of entropy so
so given that you're performing some
operation with some set of initial state
probabilities we can say okay that's a
computation or you can think of it as a
computational scenario and we're gonna
study entropy ejection in those
scenarios so again this is Landauer's
original definition it's sort of the
popular definition in the computer
science community of what a reversible
operation is and like I said it's this
one-to-one map from bold state to new
state and indeed you know if you want to
define an operation and say that entropy
is not ejected for that operation no
matter what the initial probabilities
are then this is the only way to do it
all right and that's true and then that
leads to this whole traditional theory
of reversible computing based on some
things you might have heard of like
fredkin gates and toughly gates and
controlled-not gates and you know
there's a very nice beautiful theory of
what you can build out of those things
and it's been widely used in quantum
computing because quantum computing
needs this sort of full reversibility
for quantum algorithms to work and
that's all very well and good but if the
goal is just to save energy
computation this turns out that's not
the most general model of reversible
operations even classical reversible
operations so here's the definition I
propose or you can say you know we can
use this definition alongside the other
one but this is a definition of logical
irreversible computations where a
computation now includes the operation
being performed and the statistical
operating contacts the probability
distribution over initial States well it
turns out all that we have to do to
avoid ejecting entropy is to one-to-one
transform just the states that have
nonzero probability some states can have
zero probability why ten states have
zero probability well we do this in
computing all the time we have functions
that have preconditions that have to be
met in order for that function to
operate in an error-free way and then we
ensure by design for that function in
the context of a larger program or for
some digital subsystem within context of
a larger system you know that those
conditions are met
right this is routinely done right we
know as designers how to ensure that
preconditions are mad right so all that
you have to do at the logical level to
avoid energy entropy ejection from the
computational state is that the states
that will actually arise will get
transformed a lot in one to one and if
the states that don't ever arise would
be mapped on to some of the same states
that's ok because if those states have
no probability associated with them
there's no entropy associated with them
there's no contribution to entropy from
those states and so you find you know
the total entropy of the probability
distribution before and after the
transformation is the same and that is
sufficient to avoid Lanterns principle
and we'll see concrete examples of
hardware for this in a second so the
rest of this is just sort of defining
some terminology but that's the key
insight and it seems like a trivial
thing to notice but the fact that this
has not been made explicit in reversible
computing theory
in the past has led to huge amounts of
confusion so
you know engineers will realize this is
true sort of intuitively and go and
design devices that are perfectly fine
as reversible devices and then the CS
theorists will come along and say wait
wait that's not a reversible device
because it's not performing a one-to-one
transformation of the whole input space
but they don't realize they're using an
overly restrictive definition of what a
reversible operation is for practical
purposes for engineering purposes this
is the right definition okay and so you
can turns out you can drastically
simulate designs for reversible machines
by taking advantage of this definition
so it allows you to do different kinds
of reversible operations that may be
much simpler to implement they're still
adequate for performing whatever
computation you want to do and so you
build out of those what introducing a
new true false anita's these are false
and you know not applicable or undefined
or don't care you could call it a don't
care state no with this long prop points
defines as an in and you do an algebra
to false in and I need words yeah I mean
yeah there are ways to represent this
algebraically certainly oh yeah right
you know I would love for people to go
and develop a whole algebraic theory of
you know how you compose these things so
that would be okay well fortunately it's
being recorded so you can send them the
youtube link okay so that sort of
generalized reversible competing theory
and now let's talk about circuits
there's a whole history of development
of this concept of adiabatic circuits
and it really started with fredkin and
hopefully they did a um a darpur a pre
proposal actually way back in 1978 and
where they proposed this idea that let's
shuttle charge around between inductors
and capacitors and when you switches to
control where the charge goes
and you know drill the timing of those
very carefully and so that was sort of
the beginnings of a concept but it
wasn't fully fleshed out as to how you
would do logic with that sites at
Caltech did some more work on this but
his his circuits were not completely
adiabatic he didn't realize you could do
universal computing with those circuits
and and then there were some further
developments at the physics of
computation workshop in 92 basically
several groups and apparently came up
with a way that you could do arbitrary
combinational logic in CMOS and
adiabatic circuits but they weren't sure
you could do sequential logic yet then
Saeed Yunus and Tom Knight who was
Thomas my adviser to my team came up
with the first sort of fully adiabatic
general sequential circuit technique so
basically any sequential reversible
operation or you know state machine that
you could define you could then
implement that in adiabatic CMOS in a
sort of systematic way this technique
took a lot of transistors and they came
up with a simpler version of it in 94
called SC RL for split-level charge
recovery logic it turned out at SCR
alpha that bug which I discovered during
my dissertation work it's easy to fix
the bug but we developed several chips
before we actually found the bug so
these chips we thought they were going
to be fully adiabatic and and they
weren't but we do happen we know how to
fix the bug now so they could be redone
but these were yeah so yeah I gave one
of my talks one said is pmbl
International Symposium multivalued
logic so that community is interested in
this study but anyway
so yeah these were just proof-of-concept
chips in anyway these were not designed
to be particularly efficient pendulum is
sort of a MIPS style si CPU using an
instruction set reversible instruction
set that I helped to develop flat-top is
sort of a cellular automaton
architecture that in principle is
universal that a very simple cell design
and there was a memory chip and an tick
was just a irreversible implementation
of the pendulum is a so anyway you know
we've made some test chips and there
were some bugs in them and but you know
it was sort of a beginning so here's
here's the principle for how adiabatic
circuits work from a sort of electrical
engineering perspective you can think of
it as it's just the difference between
charging from a constant voltage source
and charging from a constant current
source and in this diagram you know
there's some you can imagine there's
some switches not shown that turned the
current source on and off at specific
times but in both cases let's say we
want to move some charge Q on to some
capacitor alright and you know the
conventional analysis you know for
energy dissipation is just essentially
half of the total energy coming from the
supply gets dissipated when you charge
up the capacitor and half will get
dissipated when you discharge it so it's
like one-half CV squared and each step
and for adiabatic charging with the
constant current you know it's just
simple algebra you find that the the
dissipation for moving that amount of
charge is its CV squared multiplied by
this factor RC over T which is
essentially scaling down as the
transition time becomes larger and this
is sort of just reflecting the fact that
the the quality factor of the circuit is
higher at lower frequencies so so you
can gain an advantage and energy
dissipation from adiabatic charging
and that's all well and good but then
how do you do
how do you do logic with that well
here's where the generalized reversible
computing Theory starts to be useful
because you can actually describe at a
logical level what a transistor is doing
and you can see why there's a regime in
which what the transistor is doing is
reversible logically reversible
according to the generalized definition
which traditional reversible competing
theory didn't handle at all so this
suggests a simple sequence of operation
I'll just explain it with reference to
the pitcher we start out with output
node B that's initially zero and a
driving though B that's also
additionally zero and we have a gate
node a that you know in the first step
you can set a to some value write a new
value zero or bond and that's going to
turn this transistor on or not we'll
assume that the ones here are strong
ones and the ones here are weak ones so
that you know we don't hit the threshold
of that transistor when we're charging
but anyways this transistor is either on
or off then the driving signal here just
ramps up over some period of time and
this is the T from the previous slide I
wraps up to some new level right and so
B is connected to the driving node and a
is turned on then it will follow the
driving known you know it's some small
lag depending on how fast you do this
but it'll follow it up to that new level
and you know that's that's an adiabatic
transition that happens with you know
just that small amount of energy
dissipation determined by how fast you
do the charging and you can undo that
you know you can ramp the driving node
back down and when you look at what's
happening logically you can you can see
that most of the input States get mapped
one to one on the output States but
there are cases that don't so for
example that B was not initially 0 if
that precondition was not met and then
you happen to set a to 1 right and D is
initially 0 well now you'll have a
sudden flow of current across the
transistor because you've got a voltage
drop across it
and that's irreversible physically and
you know this is logically reversible as
well so what you do is you ensure this
state has zero probability and then
there's no entropy associated with it
and no energy gets dissipated when you
turn that transistor on okay so so that
sort of connects the fundamental and our
theory of reversibility with the physics
of adiabatic circuits right and this is
why adiabatic circuits can be adiabatic
is because they're doing a generalized
reversible operations at the logical
level and that's essential you know you
can't you know you if you there's no way
physically you know that you could do a
minute one transformation if these all
have nonzero probability probabilities
okay so and that's guaranteed by
fundamental physics right so if you
believe fundamental physics you already
know there's no way to do and to
implement that that operation adiabatic
claim if it's not logically reversible
in this generalized sense yeah this
example it's just a pass gate it's a
single transistor and the reason I start
with a single transistor is because
obviously you can't build any larger
adiabatic circuits if you can't operate
even a single transistor idiomatically
right because any larger circuit is just
an assemblage of transistors and
everything you do with each of those
transistors has to be adiabatic in order
for the whole circuit to be adiabatic
when I was at UF my students developed a
simulator and Java it was a sort of
simple discrete time simulator that
could check sort of an arbitrary CMOS
circuit and our tray set of waveforms
with discrete levels and tell you is
that an adiabatic operation sequence for
that circuit a very useful little tool
we're probably going to try to
re-implement that in modern tools
and my current project it serves of no
information state essentially all right
it's the state default state before you
knew the operation it's like some fool a
percent to false new tasks propagate
keep propagating yeah sort of way to
think about it yeah well in that example
we didn't actually have three levels but
you can think of it as a third condition
which is this is a condition where
there's no information in the bed
there's it's always zero right all right
so that was just a reversible copy
operation essentially copied a to be
logically but you can also do more
complicated operations so here's a
conditional irreversible or operation
okay we just have to parallel charging
paths and here I'm using transmission
gates in each of the charging pad so we
don't have to worry about the voltage
levels they can go full swing and you
know the sequence of operation is
similar we have some driving node that's
initially 0 and the output nodes
initially 0 and then the inputs a and B
go to new logical levels these
transmission gates get turned on or off
respectively and then D transitions and
you know if a is on or B is on Q will
follow D and transition to the new value
which will then be logically equal to a
or b right so there's an or gate using
just a few CMOS transistors you actually
need eight and not four because this is
just one of the polarities of the output
and if you want dual-rail everywhere you
may need the other version of it also
but it's a very simple thing
conceptually right and this was actually
invented long long ago so you know some
of the very earliest implementation
schemes for reversible computing some of
their early superconducting schemes and
early nanomechanical schemes and and you
know slices work you basically use this
concept as well I mean lots of people
sort of independently discovered this
from the
nearing world and yet a lot of the CS
theorists would say wait how is that
reversible computing it's not doing a
toughly gate yeah I don't understand
that a lot so now we know how to
understand it I mean I would argue some
people have known all along how to
understand this but I'm trying to sort
of bring it to light in the wider
community so why this is logically
reversible okay it's largely reversible
assuming certain preconditions are met
which is all that's okay and you know
why is this relevant like I said this
creates a lot of confusion the fact that
this hadn't been previously recognized
so an example of that there was a paper
in Nature communications just last year
in 2016 where some physicists they built
and tested this very simple or gate that
was conceptually the same as this except
it was mechanical it used cantilevers
and barriers instead of you know instead
of electrical signals and you know they
measured the dissipation and showed you
know it's less than KT it's less than
Landers limit reversible computing
theory must be wrong well it was
reversible it was doing exactly one of
these conditionally reversible
operations and they just didn't realize
it was reversible because they were
reading the CS theorists definition of
what a reversible operation was right so
basically these incorrect definitions
really caused a lot of damage for the
whole field because they create these
misunderstandings that lead people to
think that the fundamental theory is
wrong whereas I would say that the
traditional theory was incomplete and
you know the correct theory is is not
wrong that sort of a redundant statement
but yeah correct theory is correct so
anyway so this was all from a logic
style I invented around 2000 called to
allow for a two-level antibiotic logic
it was also a sequential logic style and
in fact it was the simplest sequential
style in the sense that you could
combine logic and latching functions
into a single structure and
save time and a clock cycle by not
having to do them separately and so this
is an example of a shift register in two
Lao and it let me see if I can play the
animation real quick not sure if this
will work but well you don't really need
the animation this is kind of showing
you what is happening here there's just
a pulse that travels down this line of
these are buffer stages and they look
symmetrical because they are they're
essentially doing the same thing in both
directions they're computing a copy of
the bid in the forward direction and
then their D computing the old copy from
the new one in the reverse direction so
you get a wave of activity that
essentially propagates down this
pipeline and so this is a truly pipeline
circuit you know every every four phases
you can have a new wave of information
flowing through the circuit you can do
logic in each of these stages in this
example these are just buffer stages so
there's no logic happening but you could
do logic in each stage so you could
basically get you know any sort of
pipeline fully pipeline sequential
circuit in this style the four phases of
clocks and you know we've got some very
nice simulation results so we actually
simulated this using a high level MOSFET
model and tsmc
180 nanometer technology which we had
the libraries for and this was work at
UF and actually the simulations were
done in 2004 and these are graphs this
shows power versus frequency and for a
conventional irreversible CMOS you know
they're just powers you know
proportional to frequency in frequencies
decreasing to the right and power is is
decreasing as you go down so you get
this one-to-one you know proportionality
between power and frequency which is
unsurprising because the energy per
circuit node is the same no matter what
the frequency is and you're just
dissipating that energy more or less
often depending on
how frequently you cycle the circuit
node for adiabatic circuits powers
quadratic in frequency because as you
slow down those adiabatic transitions
the energy dissipated per transition is
decreasing and also you're doing the
transitions less often
so you get this double slope here and
that's exactly what we got from our
simulations this only goes down so far
because eventually you run into leakage
limitations of the transistors due to
leakage but notice the best data point
we got was 1 electron volt of energy
dissipated per transistor per clock
cycle and that's amazing because that is
at least for close to 5 orders of
magnitude less than the actual energy
stored on each circuit node ok so so
we're getting away with dissipating only
you know one hundredth of a percent or a
tenth of a percent of no one hundredth
of a percent or less of the of the
energy so that's pretty good now that
was sort of assuming ideal power supply
is rail drivers for those ramps and if
you build a real resonator it's not
gonna you're not gonna get a Q that's
you know ten thousand or a hundred
thousand more likely you'll get a Q you
know even using good components that's
maybe tens or hundreds we had a project
for a while at UF where we thought okay
maybe let's build a resonator with MEMS
components electromechanical resonators
because those can have accused in the
thousands and and maybe that's a good
combination but that turned out if we
didn't have much funding for that
project and turned out to be too hard to
do within the scope of the funding we
had but maybe we're training again at
some point here's a simpler approach you
can do in the meantime you could build a
trapezoidal waveform generator just by
essentially you just need resonators for
the fundamental frequencies fundamental
frequency and the harmonics
for that for that signal so with with
six terms in the Fourier series or six
six harmonics you can get within one or
two percent of the ideal waveform you
can't really see it there but there's a
night ideal way for them and then
there's the actual Fourier series and
they're so close together you can't
really tell them apart and this is an
exaggerated error so you can see the
vertical scale so that's nice
you can potentially build a resonator
like that just by having parallel
bandpass filters and not filters
essentially for these for those
fundamental frequencies so if you can
tune these components precisely enough
and then you can excite this whole
circuit with a waveform of the right
shape to get the right relative
amplitudes for all the frequency
components and in principle you can
generate that whole waveform resonantly
which with some cue that's determined by
the the parasitics of the structure
right and so we've got a project right
now where we're gonna try to actually
build a resonator like this with sort of
the best available components with some
sort of custom packaging and just see
how high IQ we can get for the
trapezoidal waveform and then that will
be well-suited for actually driving a
real demonstration circuit and our goal
would be to show that you can actually
save energy and practice for you know
useful combinational circuits like we'll
build things like counters and so on and
show you know you can run a counter with
maybe 10 to 100 times less energy per
cycle then then you can do with any
conventional CMOS that's what we hope to
show okay so that's adiabatic CMOS and
I'm about out of time aren't I so I've
gone a little longer okay I won't spend
a lot of time in this slide this is just
sort of an introductory slide on
reversible superconducting circuits I'm
not gonna try to explain a detail how
they work because I'm still learning
about this area myself so I'm still
fuzzy on some of the details but
basically these have been in development
since the late 70s
concepts for how to do adiabatic
operations using superconducting
circuits and the degrees of freedom are
different in a superconducting circuit
you work with phase differences and
loops and magnetic fields and current
pulses and so it's a different domain
than CMOS but you know a lot of the
principles are similar so you still need
external control lines like an adiabatic
CMOS and there's overheads associated
with those one very new project this was
an idea I just came up with last year or
it's something I've been thinking about
since the early 2000s but I sort of
finally figured out how to do this last
year is a sort of asynchronous ballistic
style of reversible computing and this
is something that's never really been
described before but you know the goal
is to is to define devices that operate
reversibly but where the inputs arrive
at different times instead of at the
same time and that's to prevent input
signals from sort of interfering with
each other and increasing the
uncertainty of the relative timing when
they interact and they have to have
state as a consequence in order to do
logic and I came up with a simple set of
devices that appears to be universal or
is universal for for reversible
computing end and irreversible competing
embedded within reversible competing and
so here's an example of this is
essentially doing a NAND operation we
have a pulse that comes in here on this
control line bounces off this gate of
what I called a toggle barrier toggles
at state then you have a data pulse that
comes in here and either passes through
or gets routed around to this other path
so the net effect of this if it's
prepared in the correct initial state is
it gives you a logical and of the inputs
and some other stuff but the inputs
don't have to arrive at the same time in
fact they should not arrive at the same
time
so this is sort of easier to work with
it's hard to coordinate timing in a
ballistic computing system and so here
we just don't try to coordinate timing
this slide has a lot of words I'm not
going to go through all that but just to
say that we're trying to implement this
with superconducting circuits it seems
appropriate but helium helium
temperatures are good for for like
niobium and other materials there's some
nice work recently showing that indeed
you can get nearly elastic interactions
of so flux ons are these units of signal
and superconducting circuits they're
essentially a quantum of magnetic flux
and in this work they basically showed
that you can do things like buffers and
not gates that only dissipate a few
percent of the signal energy when the
winner pulse passes through the device
and so we're hoping to build our
asynchronous reversible devices in a
similar fashion so flux quanta or flux
ons can come into the device interact
with it possibly change its state
reversibly and come out and most of that
energy is preserved and then the idea of
that is you could go through many stages
of logic before you have to do
resynchronization and signal level
restoration but the point is that you
lower the overheads needed to to do
things reversibly so you don't have to
clock every stage this is an even more
far-out concept and these ideas go back
to the early 90s and work some work by
Eric Drexler but this is a group out of
the Institute for molecular
manufacturing and they actually figured
out a way that you could do reversible
logic using only rotary bearings so this
is to eliminate all sliding interfaces
and the rotary bearings are nice because
you can
with single atomic bonds okay so this is
a single carbine bond the top and bottom
of this some of this rotor here and they
analyze frictional coefficients and that
structure and got some extremely small
values yeah so the so they did some
detailed molecular dynamics simulations
and got similarly dissipation of four
times ten to the minus twenty six joules
per cycle at 100 megahertz well that's
seventy four thousand times lower than
the Landauer limit for irreversible
operations so it really shows the
potential benefit of reversible
computing and notice the speed is still
respectable in fact you could run this
structure probably at a gigahertz and it
would still work although the
dissipation would be somewhat larger but
probably still thousands of times better
than Landauer's limit let me actually
see if I can play this animation so you
can get a feel for what's happening
there and the logical structure this is
just a shift register again and the
logical structure is essentially the
same as that electrical one I showed
earlier but all the steps here are
mechanical and they're all reversible
and this whole thing is supposed to be
driven by you know a set of cam wheels
all right so you know I don't think
they've done a complete mechanical
analysis of the entire structure with
all of the of the possible modes
included so you know this results may be
somewhat optimistic but I still think
they nicely Illustrated that we are
still very far from any fundamental
limits on how efficient reversible
computing can be sorry yeah you can kind
of get a feel for the link scale from
from this diagram so you know you can
see that this is just keep losing the
button here you know this structure is
you know what's that about you know
nanometer or so thick just a few atomic
diameters thick and and the total
distance between the rotors you know
maybe that's 10 or 20 nanometers or
something okay so this is a pretty small
structure rain and you know at the
larger scale this is probably hundreds
of nanometers long in this lock
structure basically the operation of
this is one of those blue bars can be
shifted out of position but only one of
them at a time just because of the
geometry of this structure so that's
essentially your bit storage element so
that's very beautiful stuff I think
alright so in conclusion you know we
have this problem that you know the raw
performance within any reasonable power
constraints of computing as is
approaching some limits that ultimately
are rooted in very fundamental
thermodynamic issues and various kinds
of unconventional computing concepts aim
to reduce inefficiencies at just
different levels in computing and that's
all great but you know if you only
attack one or a few of the levels you
can only reduce energy dissipation by a
certain factor and also there's the
bottom most level of the fundamental
thermal limits of individual devices and
if you can't decrease those more than a
certain factor that's going to
fundamentally limit the improvements you
can get and so the only way that you can
possibly continue improving over many
orders of magnitude all the way down to
the lowest levels is to do reversible
competing in some form and people say
well what about quantum computing uh
don't get me wrong crawling computing is
great I wrote a chapter on it during my
dissertation work but you know corn
computing really only helps for certain
problems that speeds up certain
exponentially fast algorithms for
certain problems essentially quantum
computing is not really designed to be
an energy efficient on conventional
computations that's not the focus of
quantum computer design at all
and you know the implementations don't
really address energy efficiency so so
you essentially have to do reversible
computing maybe eventually someday
reversible and quantum computing will
merge and we'll have quantum computers
that are also energy efficient for
classical reversible computations okay
so we gave some overview of reversible
computing and I would argue this is the
really the only way forwards in the long
term if we don't want industry to
stagnate relatively soon we have to
begin working intensively on sort of
making the stuff more practical fleshing
out the designs going in more depth on
the on the research in general and you
know to try to make it happen you know
before everyone gets used to sort of a
state of stagnation in the industry and
I would hate hate to see that happen
because I think there's a great future
ahead of us in competing as we pursue
this path ok that's it sorry I went over
you